Donald Trump exploded on his own former
Attorney General William Barr calling
him a gutless pig because William Barr
gave a sober and sensible legal analysis
which indicated the indictment against
Trump is very serious Trump's early
argument about how other presidents did
the same thing aren't very good and that
Trump is toast if even half of the
indictment is accurate in response
Donald Trump losing his mind on Troth
Central posting quote virtually everyone
is saying that the capital I indictment
is about election interference and
should not have been brought
except Bill Barr a disgruntled former
employee and lazy attorney general who
was weak and totally ineffective he
doesn't mean what he's saying it's just
misinformation bars doing it because he
hates Trump for firing him he was
deathly afraid of the radical left when
they said they would impeach him he
knows the indictment is bull turn off
Fox News when that gutless pig is on and
again
when you listen to what William Barr
says and then you see that Trump rebuts
none of the actual legal claims and
Trump is not a lawyer and Trump has no
idea what's being said
in this particular case doesn't mean you
have to like either of them I believe
Willian Bart William Barr's analysis
comes much closer to getting to the
heart of this indictment than does
trumps which is it was election
interference and I did nothing wrong
after the break we will look at Lindsey
Graham subjected to just very light
questioning about these issues wild wild
stuff quick break and back with that